[Music]
hey Ichi live fans I'm Liana Galera and
I'm so thrilled because today we're
talking all about famous and loved
because Bella Thorne and Carter Jenkins
are joining me because season 2
premieres tonight can you guys believe
it honestly I can't I feel like it was
pretty fast I feel like we literally
just ended then now it's it's right here
yeah I'm hearing I feel the opposite
it's been forever
everyone perceives time a little bit
differently for all you fans who are
tuning in right now send us your
questions that you have for Bella and
Carter because we'll be getting to them
towards the end of the interview but
we've got to talk about the biggest
cliffhanger of season 1 when we last
left off you know you guys were sitting
at a press conference and looking oh so
cute and then all the sudden you got
interrupted and you were asked the very
infamous question are you with your
roommate or your co-star I just tell us
saying that that that who page chooses I
think is the wrong person in my opinion
I yes but I I think that it is an
interesting one and of course it only
brings more other lovebirds in the
series together you know you know what
I'm saying
how long do fans have to wait until they
find out who pages chosen it's the first
act the first act
don't miss that yeah don't miss the very
beginning like you have to tune in
because there it is boom front and
center you don't want to be like 2
minutes late yeah I think you want to
watch it live oh yes because you want a
live tweet along with it as well yeah
we're gonna live-tweet yeah but also you
know you don't want it spoiled for you
this is true and it's a big spoiler well
so the interesting thing that I don't
think that fans really know is that we
get a little bit of a time jump in
between season 1 and season 2 we get
about
two months so what can you tease that
Rainer husband up - well a lot changes
in those two months and you're gonna be
playing catch-up you know to figure out
what what's happened but when we last
saw Rainer he had fallen off a wagon
pretty hard yeah and you know he's
definitely working on getting healthy
and you know rage would have no chance
if this guy is off you know with his
addiction so he's working on getting
healthy well and I love we were just
talking about it before we went live we
still have to talk about rage is a
really cool ship name it I mean it is
honestly it was one of the really
exciting things when fans put that name
together and we were just like that is
it there is another one that was pretty
good too well I was like come on rage
like that is like I feel like that's
also our characters kind of chemistry
like pretty much almost had ever seen
together it's always like it's like rage
you guys do have really great chemistry
together though how did you guys find
that on-screen connection off screen
just acting yeah honestly we really
don't hang out we're not like very close
off of set but one more on set we hang
out but we know each other for a while
yeah I was being sarcastic I know one of
the things I'm not going to give it away
for fans but in tonight's episode page
post something on social media and she
gets so much backlash from the fans out
there the Internet can be so cruel how
do you guys as actors deal with backlash
when you sign on to social media and see
your newsfeed is just flooded with mean
comments I think the main way to go
about it is is is literally the fact of
just dealing with it there
it's it's not like people could say
anything and depending on what
insecurity it pushes you know it's gonna
depend on how deep it gets and so for me
it's like some things I'm like that's
actually funny other things I'm like I
don't know you just sound really
ignorant right now and then there's the
last one and I'm just like oh that's
actually right on the nail you really
got me on the inside and those are the
ones definitely that that hurt but I
also feel like that is so much of what
we do is is you know rejection and all
of that stuff that comes along with the
great things and so kind of getting used
to it
is really what I do always building a
thicker skin because it's never gonna
stop like people are always gonna have
something you know negative to say yeah
I think the other thing that I try to
remember is that you know you can put
your phone away and it's all gone yeah
you know and and that's powerful
disconnect for a little bit and connect
with the people in your real life and
the people that you have around you and
I mean that's that's one route but it
can be it can be that can be tough
mm-hmm but I think that six goodness
you've got a real thick skin that's
impressive
Bela you almost gave your fans a heart
attack because you tweeted that you were
gonna be off of social media for the
rest of 2018 it was would you ever
consider leaving social media for good
though yeah yeah yeah I think that
there's definitely look I I love social
media I love where it I think where it
stems from for me is a lot of people
like to hate but it's just it really
it's so crazy because the fact that we
can talk to someone that we'd really
never be able to talk to you know not
really get the chance and and learned so
much about their cultures and the photos
and like you know
everything about it is really amazing
but you know of course then there is
again the naked
side of it and kind of what social media
is turned a little bit more into but
there's definitely great parts of it I
don't know how long I would really ever
step off for but I could see myself
maybe you know definitely I also think
social media might die down one day and
remember that time when we posted a
photo of us doing every single thing in
our day a bird but it also is a good way
to express yourself and just kind of
show what you guys have been up to one
of the things that I love so much about
famous and loves first episode is that
we get to see Paige in a different role
and she's in Jake's movie stealing
Georgia and she has a bit of an edge
year look then Paige would typically
have what did that feel for you to be
able to step into that edgier side as
Paige
well I was definitely that's not a photo
of me looking edgy that is actually a
photo of me trying to look more cleaned
up but yeah as the character was quite
fun because you know it's it's very soon
on and as soon as I open the script and
I'm reading this part it says like you
know Bella
esque like Bella edgy and I'm like and
and I was excited when I went in for the
original like meeting and they were like
oh and you get to have your septum
piercing out and I was like no way bro
are you serious this thing is gonna make
it on screen I can't even believe that
so I was really excited about not having
to put my nose piercing out because it
really hurts I'm gonna have to put it up
all day and then you have to take it
down yeah people constantly go see me
going like this and like belts pick your
nose again I'm like I'm literally
adjusting my septum piercing I'm sorry
it looks a little bit disturbing but I'm
not picking my nose when it is flipped
up can you feel it does it feel awkward
it's just so you really can't see it at
all right yeah this is why I got it yeah
I got actually got it while filming
famous a month the first season and I
went to set the next day and I had to
put it up and as they
recommend that don't don't get it right
before it's a great excuse when you pick
your nose too right going through season
three oh yeah I love that page okay so
this is Anna spoiler page almost makes a
really big purchase in season one or in
Episode one of season two what have you
guys splurged on with your famous love
checks anything like super cool that
you're like I'm on a hit show here's
what I want to buy um I think the key to
making money is not looking at money
like that yeah I think that's definitely
the biggest part like it is nice to like
you you see something and you want it
but well for me right now at least I'm
not really trying to buy anything big
I'm saving money to buy a property for
an organization that I'm starting so I
don't know I don't really look at this
organization that you're looking to
start well it's actually I'd like to I
like to think of it as like a a sponsor
means big little campaign meets like a
life coach and awesome I'd be us taking
these kids out of the housing situations
that they're in and kind of like
starting from the bottom up like you
know do you have to get a GED how do we
get you there do you need tutoring do
you have to get tested you know what
what do you want to do in life do you
want to figure out this how do you get a
credit card I didn't know anything when
I turned 18 and and I felt so angry with
myself because I was like I feel dumb I
feel like I don't even know where to
start but I think that's kind of how a
lot of people feel and that's what will
be helping these kids
that's great yeah that's amazing that
you want to use your notoriety as a
platform to help others it's like why
would you have a pot farm if you're not
gonna use it to help others why would
you know like why aren't you
why are you person and you're not going
to like use yourself as a human being to
help others it just kind of is
especially right now in the world when
everyone's in such a dire need of help
yeah it's just seems a little bit
ridiculous not to definitely I bought a
projector yeah you're outside Oh from my
room oh that's cool it's great I go to
sleep on that it's like I have a movie
theater right there amazing that's not
helping anybody except for me it's so
nice like it's so I haven't done much
with my life yeah you guys got a pretty
little director this season Troian
Bellisario directed an episode of famous
in love what was that like to have her
what do you think though I never talked
to you about that um amazing I love her
I love that it's so nice to meet a
director that's an actor's director you
know she worked so much off the scenes
with us and that was really a great part
was was having a director that was
really willing to like okay let's dive
in deeper you know and she's also very
personable she does great under heavy
working conditions which sounds like not
that big of a deal but honestly it can
we can tear apart a set very quickly you
know if if your director isn't a proper
leader in the sense there's lots of
difficult things that happen what one
you're shooting so that's so true I'm
right there with you she was incredible
yeah yeah it was a great review she's a
she I mean she's been doing this type of
television for a long time and she she
was great she went right there with us
to all the emotional places we had to go
and she had great ideas and she
respected our ideas as actors she's got
a future
I just love because I had the pleasure
of interviewing her while she was
directing and her Pretty Little Liars
episode and she takes it very seriously
a lot of people think that when actors
step behind the screens they're like oh
okay sure that's just what you're trying
to do but she really did take it
seriously so it's nice - and she also
wrote a movie called feed which is
amazing I just watched it like a week
ago everyone should watch it she took a
thing and she kind of made something
that usually should be the center of
attention and she gave it such a story
around it it's really great he's anybody
who's watching watch that movie one of
the things that I'm so excited about
with the second season of famous and
loved is as the title suggests we still
get to see what it's like when people in
the Hollywood spotlight deal with a
being in a relationship because it's a
tricky thing you guys are both in really
great relationships in real life how you
guys navigate the spotlight while still
having that loving person to be with
well I think for me it's been you know
the work life and then the personal life
balance can be tricky because I love
what I do and I take it really seriously
and you know it's hard not to take it
home but there's times when you you just
got to put the phone away and you know
put the script away and just be with
your person mm-hmm yeah that's what I've
been working on you and Maude seem to
have such a good almost like soul
connection you just seem to really get
each other we actually do we really get
each other yeah I got I got lucky we
were always constantly stealing each
other's thoughts which is quite fun but
I think the way we kind of work it out
is we just try to make sure that we
don't go very long without seeing each
other I think is really important
because so many things I believe that
like really building a bond with some
is having your harshest moments with
that person because that takes it to
such a deeper level I got really lucky
also though with Maude because we've
literally never had an argument and
we've been dating almost seven months
isn't that insane if that's me not gonna
listen yeah but like isn't that
literally so weird to hear I've never
been in a relationship like that before
like ever like he just literally looks
at me and he's like great babe
everything you're doing I love it I
support it I love you it's amazing you
just think he's just so nice which is
amazing and you deserve that like and I
loved that you were so open about some
of the things that you've been going
through in your past and you were really
open about that in 2017 so it must've
been so great to have this stable person
and your like to really just fall back
with and just relax with yeah 100% when
I actually posted I was I was laying in
bed right next to him so my initial
trying reaction of like kind of being
like was with him and my manager on the
phone because I called him right after
and so it was me Maude my manager came
in and we all just kind of laid on the
bed well we're starting to get so many
really great fan questions from you guys
right now Ricardo from facebook says
Bella with the development of the show
what have you seen your what have you
seen yourself in Paige's journey at some
point Oh have you seen yourself in
Paige's journey at some point that's a
good question um there's definitely a
lot of things that relate that I'm like
do you guys have a mic in my dressing
room when I said this who put this in
there I know you guys something sketchy
is going on behind closed doors
there's definitely quite a few moments
specifically of well the the shitstorm
that Paige goes through there's the big
purchase that Paige goes through there's
actually the I don't want to give away a
spoiler but there is someone that's
after Paige and in in in this series
that is it's very scary and I have had
that same situation in in my life as
well actually like a few weeks later
than shooting that episode and I was
like okay this is really coincidental
what oh but yeah and definitely just I
think dating in the public eye some of
the small things that Paige goes through
and her heart wants I feel like I
definitely can relate to that yeah
Carter Kayla from YouTube wants to know
what is your best slash funniest memory
from set Kayla from YouTube what
happened this year funny funny moments
from Seth had some good times mmm what
happened this year you know it's kind of
hard cuz it's like there are definitely
funny moments but it's not like anyone
ever you know we're we like to have fun
but we're professionals when we're there
we were there to do our job and every
minute you are there literally it's
money out of someone's pocket so if
you're wasting someone's time it's not a
good thing and especially all the crew
members that are on set you know you
always want to be like as professional
as they are or more you know you always
want to keep that up and so for us we
like to have fun but it's not like we
ever pull anything big like a joke like
I don't know first season I would always
go into Charlie's dressing room and
change things in his dressing room and
just say use his bathroom all the time
steal his blanket and I just always take
videos going into his dressing room when
he wasn't there so he knew like I'd post
them like on my story inside but I kind
of didn't do that the season along
because I was like maybe it really I've
grown up a lot yeah yeah maybe a little
bit of invasion of privacy
[Music]
blankets anymore
[Laughter]
Oh Riverdale oh nine from YouTube wants
to know how was it working with Sophia
so great yeah sorry we're gonna gush
about Rupert oh really quick can we get
you one yeah this network will allow it
I think that with your red hair it would
be Xuan to play a relative of Sheryl
oh that that that's that's a very good
that is that you you're getting some
points on the back end for that one I I
someone is listening all right we're
gonna tweet Madelaine Pech afterwards
and we're gonna get this go sorry back
to Riverdale oh nine from YouTube she
wants to know how is it working with
Sophia Carson and Danielle Campbell mmm
we have two new guest stars on famous
and loved this year REO Craig's yes
lucky we got some good some good new
guest actors on the show Sofia's like
big-time from The Descendants and she
was what's a lovely oh yeah big time she
was she was awesome
oh so he's a great character she really
gets in there her character is really
quite fun it's when anytime you see here
on the screen you know there's something
kind of going down so that's really cool
and Danielle she's causing a lot of
drama
yeah the new girls causing drama
oh yeah we got we are lucky we also got
just so lucky in general with casting
cuz you know you never know who what
let's set your stepping on and who
you're working with and we really got
lucky cuz all of our customers are so
chill we're all just like chillin you
know and that's Sabella sets the tone
yeah that was chilling so we're all like
yeah well chime that call she's very um
Jennifer from facebook says Carter what
made you audition for the role of Rainer
and Bella I dare you to tell us who's
your favorite guy to kiss
Carter Charlie or Keith Oh
why are you gonna do that you know maybe
go ferns
okay I'll answer and then you think
about it I I audition for this show
you know actually audition for Jake and
ringer really yeah and I didn't know
which one I liked more because there at
times in my life I feel like Jake and
then times in my life I've felt like
Rainer so I didn't know which one I
identified with more and then I when I
tested I tested for both parts and they
they called and said I got the job and I
said
we draw and my my agent was like Rainier
I really felt like they made a mistake
he's gonna say Bella how do you feel if
he was we knew when we when he walked in
that it was his ringer it was kind of
also just it was like there's clearly no
without Carter on the show it's either
he's he's one of the characters and then
but but when we I think we did Jake
first I think we did Jake scenes first
and then we did Rayner and and you
walked out of the room and it was just
very kind of clear like straight up I
was arena right there well I don't know
that that's really cool fellow would you
like to go back to the other question
would you I would III think it is did
well okay you did well Charlie's not
here Rick from YouTube says Bella I
loved all of your songs in Midnight Sun
is there any chance we could see Paige
singing in the show once a month well
man will not be a fun contractor right
up especially with my record label but I
don't know I mean I wonder I feel like
Paige yeah that would be interesting
yeah we're even used by Mary okay night
good night out with the whole group yeah
but like who realistically sings amazing
at karaoke okay you do know know is
wrong I don't even sing karaoke
I'll just straight up it's either I rap
a little Wayne song or I sing
Billy Idol or don't jet or Billy Squier
as well but anywhere in between
I can't I'm not singing it okay yeah
it's not about yeah right oh god who's
got some ideas I hate karaoke really
it's my worst fear like that it's the
most self-conscious I've ever got
but maybe Rainer likes it so I would I'm
imagining like like a duet what are we
gonna say like colt 45
you know what I think we should sing
[ __ ] I'm Bella Thorne
um everyone is saying please rap for us
right now all the fans are saying please
freestyle oh no I'm not selling right
now actually just spent all day in 90s J
recording a new song that is really cool
and I love it and I just want to say
that but I'm not going to rap you when
could we hear this new song new song
well vision poll turns to come out first
okay but I have everything cued up and
ready for that one but then I have
another song lined up behind that so
we'll have to see when it comes out but
it is very poppin if you know what I'm
saying not pop like it's not pop like
it's pop in would you ever let mod come
on and guest sing on one of your songs
oh well modern I actually write a lot of
music together and we're working on an
EP together as well that's kind of um a
little bit of like a 60s blues 5 it's
just quite interesting for the both of
us to do but yeah we have features on
each other's songs as well he was
actually going to be on the pitch in
both Lauryn song we're gonna put a
future and heads and instead he was like
no no
now I just say his name in the song I'm
still a fan of the old the early Bella
Thorne stuff you know I'm talking about
sure like I'm talking about Jersey you
know I have them on my phone
boyfriend okay right that's my it's so
good it honestly it's a really great
song yeah and and Jersey is still like
pop my sister poor thing
every time she turns on like her phone
and plugs it into the auxiliary it plays
my music it's the only thing that's like
downloaded everything else is like from
Spotify I guess so it just like straight
up plays it as soon as she plugs it in
and it's always just blasting paper wait
I have the same thing yeah and my car
okay really die oh you don't think of me
every time you get into your car
geez everywhere um I could chat with you
guys about famous and love all day but
unfortunately we are out of time but for
all you kidding right now for all you
fans tune in to freeform tonight because
famous and loved season 2 premieres at 8
p.m. and these amazing people will be
live-tweeting
yeah we will be and you got to see who
who I choose cuz who knows at this point
[Music]